this happened yesterday afternoon yeah
Hollywood Reporter tweeted out that
they're talking about a prequel in
development with the original writer and
director of the Sandlot so what are they
gonna follow the kids when they were
eight seven when they're born I don't
really
what's the prequel don't really know
what the prequel like who would be the
prequel be like before smalls his family
moved in like what the game was like or
Denis Leary's character you're they're
gonna focus on him maybe but they
remember they moved to that neighborhood
because Denis Leary's character took a
new job or something and we're now Aaron
Allen was the wife beast the dog right
you know what there's Jesse James Earl
Jones he played on this legendary
Yankees team so maybe they dick you know
dig back in his character if they're
gonna do any sports movie prequel that I
would pay to see we were talking about
this that I would want to see we were
talking about this that I would want to
see I could think of a couple it would
be coach Dale pre Hoosiers what happened
to caused him to lose his gig and have
to reinvent himself to go and coach that
team in in Indiana I would that's what I
would absolutely see that okay
I would also pay to see from either his
high school days Rudy defrauding his
coach to get on the field in that film I
would see that Rudy was faking faking
all at the defrauding and faking to get
himself on the field prior to getting to
Notre Dame um I would pay to see that
one you don't wanna see Crash Davis work
his way through the minor leagues maybe
have a cup of coffee though memory tells
the story about we also know where he's
gonna go back we know where all these
stories go that's understandable know
you really want to see Bull Durham a
prequel to Bull Durham
what about tin cup playing college golf
with Todd Johnson and then what how he
the rails came
for his career in his life okay kind of
interesting what about what he
Harrelson's character Higa and i white
men can't jump
can you watch you play college ball how
he got into hustling the Stookey
brothers maybe Wesley Snipes what about
the California Penal League you know
wanna see Ricky Vaughn Tom Shirley Tom
Berenger scurry Oh some of these I just
don't want to Serrano okay what about
I mean we're there's no natural there's
no prequel to the natural there's no
prequel to the natural now what about
you know or what happened with but to
Roy Hobbs between getting shot and then
reappearing like a deep dark base but
you know the natural is a dark story in
real in the in the Bernard Malamud in
the book right book is dark spoiler
alert
Roy takes the money in the book right
all right so they really lightened that
up for the movies we can't have evil
Robert Redford but I mean you know I
can't I can't
that's a good one Apollo Creed movie
well we're seeing it already but I'd
rather see a prequel on I'd rather see a
prequel of the two characters in the
rocky I'd rather see a prequel on Paulie
right I've been to that okay or Mick
Mick would be good all the fighters that
he'd seen beforehand or a little burgess
Meredith prequel I'd see that maybe will
sneak in a call 844 204 rich when I come
back Gordon Bombay is like youth career
just saying but some sports movies just
shouldn't be touched but a prequel to
Hoosiers I'd see that I would see that
who plays coach Dale who plays coach
Dale in a younger coach Dale uh who's a
younger looking Gene Hackman Gene
Hackman Ed Harris
Brimley he's like the Benjamin Button he
was 51 shooting cocoon Tom Cruise was 56
doing his know he's running past the
London Eye like Runner of 40 on a runner
on a broken ankle Minh was healing the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience